Being on SCP-173 detail isn’t easy.
These duties of strict observation fall on
a bi-weekly basis when SCP-173’s enclosure
needs to be cleaned.
The reddish-brown substance on the floor is
a natural output of SCP-173, a combination
of feces and blood.
While the Foundation has put up with a lot
of depraved behavior from its SCPs, it draws
the line at poor hygiene.
They routinely send in a crew of three D class
personnel to clean up the mess.
But the bigger chore isn’t the scrubbing
and mopping at all, but rather keeping SCP-173
docile.
To do so, the line of sight must not be broken
at any time with SCP-173.
Personnel assigned to enter the container
are instructed to alert one another before
blinking.
If this protocol is not followed, SCP-173
attacks by snapping the neck at the base of
the skull.
It is, at its core, a high-stakes staring
contest.
The crew is intelligently divided into their
tasks.
Only one of them actually has janitorial duties.
And even then, the mopper’s most relevant
skill isn’t even related to cleaning at
all.
His greatest strength must be his ability
to trust other people.
As he takes his mop to the floor, he hands
over his life to his crew, who protect him
with their focus and attention on SCP-173.
It is without a doubt one of the cruelest
and most stressful jobs anyone could ever
have.
But not every horror story is found in the
trenches of terror.
Those with mops on the frontlines have their
work cut out for them, but even the researchers
with their warm lab coats and boring bureaucratic
obligations aren’t safe from danger.
This is the story of Jake Scholl, a researcher
who - for reasons we will tactfully tease
you with until the video's witty end - had
been reassigned to SCP-173.
Director Fordham brought the bad news like
a bag of coal.
"You're being reassigned," he said, with a
slight smirk on his face, continuing to be
preoccupied with his paperwork, as if this
news was secondary to what he was doing right
there and then.
But it wasn’t secondary to Jack Scholl.
It was the center of their life.
No.
Not even just the center.
It was the center, peripheral, and outer bounds
of their life.
Their assignments were everything.
And everything was about to change.
A pregnant silence followed the announcement.
Jake Scholl couldn’t find a response, and
they weren't even sure there was one to be
found, no matter how deep they dug.
What came out wasn’t as much of a retort
as a reaction.
That involuntary bodily response to events
that weren’t expected.
That awkward and afraid muttering of fear
and confusion.
"I—.
What?
I'm being…
what?
I’m…
I’m to be reassigned.
Is that what you’re saying?"
Researcher Scholl blinked a few times, confused.
Their feet sunk into the deep forest green
shag on the floor.
A spectrum of thoughts cascaded through their
mind, as they searched harder and harder for
reason.
Digger deeper and deeper only to find another
treasure chest full of nothing.
"Is my work…not sufficient on SCP—"
Director Fordham looked up, and gave them
the fixed, pointed stare they’d grown to
dread over the past six months.
"Of course not, Jake.
I recognize what you've done, and we want
to put you somewhere I feel you deserve.
And serve the Foundation, of course.
We're putting you on a very important, and
special, object."
Again, Fordham gave that smirk.
That damn smirk.
Sure, his words and tone presented themselves
as the truth, but his face said otherwise.
The devious positioning of his lip suggested
there was a layer of sinister subtext to his
speech.
But Jake Scholl couldn’t pick up on the
cues.
There is no room to read someone else’s
poker face when all of your attention is on
the crappy hand you’ve just been dealt.
Jake Scholl's eyes fell to the desk.
Reassigned.
The word rang like church bells.
Why god!?
Their work with SCP-3872 as a consulting chemist
was going slowly, to be truthful, but they
didn't think it was to the point that they
needed reassignment.
"A-Alright.
Which project am I assigned to?"
The time between the question and the answer
was the longest of Jake’s life.
The uncertainty felt like an eternity.
Fordham tapped a few symbols accessing Scholl's
profile, and added an entry in their security
clearance.
He hastily swiped away all the other files
listed and turned back to face Scholl.
"You have access to it now.
Please get on the first plane to Site-19.
Your dormitory contents are already packed
up."
Jake reached into their pocket to check the
notifications on their cell phone.
[SCP-DB NOTIFICATION] > SCP-3872.
FILE REMOVED.
[SCP-DB NOTIFICATION] > SCP-2593.
[SCP-DB NOTIFICATION] > SCP-173.
FILE ADDED.
They turned around, and walked slowly through
the corridors, towards the transportation
hub on the outskirts of the site.
They opened the file on their phone, and quickly
scanned the oddly phrased report, attempting
to make sense of what they were reading.
Scholl's eyebrows raised to the heavens as
they noticed the timestamp on containment.
SCP-173 was one of the first.
One of the few objects that the Foundation
came to possess through some organization
or another, without losing its information.
They tried their best to remain optimistic
in their interpretation of these new life
events.
And for a moment, they thought, “This might
be a good thing for me.”
Swiping down, they came to the section about
assigned researchers, the people whose steps
they would be following in.
And where were those steps leading them?
The list was impressive, from Dr. Kondraki
to Dr. Bright.
These people were all legends in their own
right.
And so if they could just follow their footsteps,
they reasoned they would end their journey
in a good place.
They imagined their new career path straight
to the top of the mountain of success.
Maybe they would make groundbreaking discoveries.
Maybe they would become the face of the Foundation.
Maybe they would accomplish so much that there’d
be a statue erected in their honor that people
travel far and wide to visit and take pictures
with.
Maybe this would be a good thing, they wanted
to think.
"I need the first plane to Site-19,” they
said with confidence.
“I've been reassigned."
And so, Jake Scholl took to the air and clung
to this dream as long as they could.
But no matter how heavy a sleeper, reality
shakes everyone awake eventually.
Six years later.
Jake Scholl could hear the years pass.
But not only could they hear it, they could
feel it.
Their body was decaying in a way inconsistent
with our biological understanding of age.
SCP-173.
The legendary object.
The first, the original, the Statue.
It was chipping away at the soul of Jake Scholl.
It was carving a statue of its own.
Hacking at stone until it was nothing.
And that’s what Jake Scholl felt like.
Nothing.
It was torture.
When they arrived, they quickly reviewed the
research materials.
Every word had become burned into their memory.
All 233 words of them.
The "additional research materials" turned
out to be a few scribbled pages by bored researchers.
A few had made hypotheses that had all turned
out to be nonsense.
There was a locked filing cabinet, but every
time Scholl requested it be opened, maintenance
told them that the control room was designated
"low priority" and they would get to it eventually.
Over the past six years, Jake Scholl had made
18 separate transfer requests.
They wanted out.
But all of them had been denied.
It was as if they were in high school again.
Asking dates to prom and getting hit with
no thank you’s, feeling none of the politeness
baked into their syntax, understanding only
the brute reality of the phrase: “No.”
They were stuck here, technically a Level
3 staff now, but without any rights to view
or work on any other objects.
They were given a promotion but it withheld
all the perks and benefits that come with
it.
They were stuck in a loop of pats on the back.
People extended them their hand, but it was
always with an empty palm… giving them nothing
to hold onto but a gesture.
They were assigned a staff of four.
Three D-class, all of which were older men,
and a lazy level 2 Security Officer, who slouched
in his office chair, meeting the bare minimum
requirements to be considered a living human
being.
The D-class were all quite docile.
They came in once a week, mopped the floor,
mumbled "Clear '' to each other, and left.
They lived within this exact structure.
“No new days,” became an unspoken motto.
These recurring 24 hours passed slowly.
If there were no clocks to prove the passing
of time, they would have every reason to believe
it had frozen over.
But occasionally, ever so occasionally, the
day would deviate just slightly.
They’d hear something.
A scrape and the sounds of movement.
Jake would flip open the observation ports
on the double-concrete lock and examine SCP-173.
But Jake could take offense to such language.
Examining might be the wrong word.
More accurately, they would just look at it.
Because there was nothing to examine.
There was nothing to observe.
SCP-173 was already understood.
Michael Jordan doesn’t take a microscope
to the ball every time he plans to dribble.
He knows every detail of it by heart.
His fingertips know the grooves.
His hand-eye coordination knows how to control
it.
His right arm’s built-in apt for physics
knows exactly how much force to put into each
shot and at what trajectory to aim.
We are told to learn something new every day,
but the truth is, there comes a day when the
learning stops.
When we know all that we will ever know.
And this felt true to Jake.
They understood SCP-173.
There was nothing more for them to see.
It was just concrete, rebar, and some spray
paint.
That was it.
And that was all that it would ever be.
There was nothing to find, nothing to determine.
Nothing for the researcher to research.
Their job was done, but they kept having to
work it.
Their identity no longer fit, but they kept
having to put it on each and every morning.
When Jake first got there, they collected
samples of the concrete, some of the rebar,
some spray paint.
They were determined to find something worthy
of research.
After four weeks, they’d gotten sick of
getting no replies from admin, and they cracked
the lock on the filing cabinet, finding the
research notes of all the previous researchers.
All of the "legendary" doctors' notes turned
out to be doodles and random to-do lists which
had nothing to do with the object.
After six weeks they gave up on taking samples.
After eight weeks, they brought a Gameboy.
After ten, they started bringing in anything
they could to pass the time: a yoyo, a collection
of short stories, a packet of hot sauce they
felt bad throwing away, a piece of string
to cut off circulation to their index finger
for no other reason than to make sure they
were still a human relying on blood.
Oh yes, Jake Scholl was bored.
So very bored.
They thought if anyone could bring the phrase
BORED TO DEATH to fruition, it would be them.
These days, they shuffled in, waved at the
guard, and sat down at the little control
room where there was a terminal, which didn't
have an internet connection, and tried to
stay sane.
Fast forward a few years and Jake barely fit
into his chair.
To clarify, no, they did not purchase a new,
tiny chair out of boredom.
They got fat out of boredom.
Their life brought them no joy, and so what
they couldn’t get from living, they searched
for in eating.
But there was no fulfillment to be found at
the center of the tootsie pop.
Jake stood with a grunt, as the light came
on, and the three D-class were escorted to
the control room, with the mops and buckets
in tow.
"Thanks, Jimmy,” was the only conversation
they had with the new security staff.
The old guard had retired sometime in the
eighth year.
Honestly, Jake couldn't even remember.
The D-class had gotten older too, most of
them now gray-haired, but still assigned to
the project.
The security guard walked over and thumbed
towards the break room.
"Hey Jake, I'm going to get coffee.
If anything happens, seal the door, you know
the drill.
Just keep an eye on the D's."
Jake buzzed the doors open and stood inside
the door frame, keeping their eyes on the
statue most of the time, but wandering over
the containment chamber.
A long time ago, they might have been concerned,
but the D-classes they worked with weren't
violent.
Frankly, they had worked with these men long
enough that they extended a small measure
of trust.
All of them did their jobs without complaining
and had never made a mistake in ten years.
While the years of repetition wore them out,
the job itself didn’t even feel like labor.
They had perfected the art of the staring
contest.
They were confident, and they had reason to
be.
As the years went on, although they collected
no new data on SCP-173, they did collect evidence.
Evidence that they were capable of containing
it.
While they learned nothing of importance about
SCP-173, they learned about themselves.
They learned that they were a good crew.
And it was because of this confidence, even
if rightfully earned, that success crumbled.
When in a room with SCP-173 you have to assume
everything will go wrong.
Because anything can go wrong.
And eventually, it will.
And when that time comes, you have to be prepared.
Procedure said Jake had to have someone armed
in the room with any D-class.
Jake looked down at their hip, double-checking
the pistol there.
They knew how to use it but figured he never
would have to draw it.
The routine cleaning began.
"Clear."
It was the same old, same old.
Until…suddenly…
it wasn’t.
"Cl..
Cl… oh no, I think I'm having a—…" SNAP
"What, hey Nick, are you—" SNAP
"Oh god, no I don't wanna—" SNAP
Jake's eyes shot up, as the Statue stood inches
away.
Its green eyes stared directly into their
soul.
In their periphery, Jake could see the three
D-class with their heads turned at odd angles.
Jake desperately reached out for the emergency
containment button on the wall.
They hadn’t ever had to use it, and it was
supposed to be easy to find.
But of course, it wasn’t.
They recalled the manual saying, “Move your
hand anywhere along the right-hand wall, the
button takes up most of the wall.
It will seal off the containment chamber,
and SCP-173 from breaching containment.”
They moved their hand exactly how their memory
of the manual instructed him.
But it wasn't there.
There was nothing to press.
There was nothing to save them.
Jake's hands grew desperate, and their eyes
began to water.
Just as they started to close, a last thought
crossed their mind.
Move your hand anywhere along the left hand
wall, the button takes up most of the wall.
It will seal off the containment chamber,
and SCP-173 from breaching containment.
Of course, a classic mix-up.
Fifty-fifty chances never favor the flustered.
Their fight or flight instincts were contradicting
each other.
Was reaching for a button fighting or was
it flighting?
They were in their head.
Deep in trenches of overthinking.
Finally, they regained their composure.
Their hand darted out to the left, and they
started to push down on the button.
The red of the emergency button filled their
vision, as the green eyes of SCP-173 slipped
just barely out of…
SNAP!
Director Kingsley stood outside of the meeting
room, a few minutes before the weekly briefing
in the Site-217 administrative wing.
"Fordham.
Do you remember Jake Scholl?"
"Sure do."
"Just got a report from 19.
Looks like there was a breach, and they bit
it."
Fordham waved off a few colleagues who were
about to enter the meeting room.
His conversation with Director Kingsley wasn’t
over.
He went on to tell him that he was just about
to approve Jake Sholl’s transfer.
After all these years Jake had been sending
requests to leave SCP-173, their wish was
about to be granted.
But instead, they were reassigned to the grave.
What a cruel twist, isn’t it?
That is, of course, if it were actually true.
Fordham gave his patented smirk.
“Just kidding.
The only researchers to ever get out of that
post needed Friends in very high places.
Scholl, to his detriment, did not."
So what exactly did Scholl do to deserve this?
It is known that those who are sent to SCP-173
have made mistakes.
If you disrespect your boss, you might be
reassigned to SCP-173.
If you don’t follow Foundation policy, you
might be reassigned to SCP-173.
If you leak information to the public, you
If you are Jake Scholl, however, it doesn't
take quite as much.
So I will pose the question once more, “What
horrible thing could Jake have done?”
Could they have been plotting to help an array
of SCPs escape.
Could they have been smuggling dangerous equipment
from the lab and selling it on the black market.
Could they have somehow been responsible for
every casualty in Foundation history?
Or could it have been something much, much
smaller.
Like occasionally parking in their boss’s
favorite spot on site-217… a lot, you must
understand, which doesn’t have assigned
parking.
Now go check out “SCP-173 - The Complete
Story” and “SCP-173 Origin Story - How
173 Got to Site-19” for more tales of the
iconic SCP-173!